Gary Vaynerchuk a big big big deal in
the wine business and also in social
media
check this out several years ago is very
creative he took to the internet to
promote his family's wine business
Warren library comm in a pretty unique
and compelling way these videos as they
say went viral and kind of had a real
devoted following and also turned his
family's business from 4 million for
like 50 million dollars and so Gary here
is not just a wine expert anymore he is
a social media expert is the latest book
by the way got a lot of attention there
it is Jab Jab Jab right hook no it's not
about boxing it's about getting your
name out there and selling stuff I think
social media to your advantage
correct guys all right Gary Vaynerchuk
is here we're talking what do you think
wine yes and social media products do it
which goes comes first though let's talk
about the wine actually before you snag
I see you guys went quickly let's calm
it down for a second let's grab the
second one it's a Rosie there you go
second one you go if you want to pass
right there to the end appreciate it
brother this is sin so so everybody
watching right now you talk about
Chardonnay Pinot Grigio but since so the
base of this now let's give this a
snippy snip and that's a key guys you
got a smell okay now you're getting a
little raspberry you're getting a little
rose petal on the nose what else are you
guys picking up it's not fresh it smells
like rose a I mean Gary why we have to
smell I mean I figure you know we know
this is a good one you picked it the
restaurant usually does a good job this
is science my friend you smell it it
opens up the taste buds it allows you to
actually taste it but what I'm really
here to talk to you about is a mix of
wine and kind of Technology and social
media there's an app I'm excited about I
want you to grab me a bottle over there
anyone you want something sir how about
the window whatever let's do it sparkly
rosy that's that how I'm calm now watch
this I don't know if you guys are gonna
get this on the screen
I've got delectable open okay okay don't
know about showing it that's right so
now watch this you take the camera right
you point it
you point it watch this one click that
was blurry let's see what happens watch
this
check learn more about this wine this
apt delectable which I invested in so
you know I'm fully behind it okay
recognizes wines within two seconds so I
give you more information look at this
look at this it's got a rating the whole
this so this is what I've been trying to
solve since 2006 which is let's call it
what it is when somebody gets a little
bit into wine they become a straight
jerk-off yeah really get dangerous right
that's right right take it easy in other
words well I get it I get that was
actually me filtering okay so you know
and so I've been trying to find a way to
help people become to both wine
technology's gonna solve this we showed
them the iPad but it's on the phone in
two seconds you get to see what the wine
is that's gonna make people more
comfortable I love it even make yourself
knowledgeable before you get drunk so
afterwards you can remind yourself what
you drink
imagine going to imagine going to the
store I guarantee ninety percent of the
people watching right now pick by the
label or by a reading now now give it
three or four minutes you take six or
seven photos ten photos you get feedback
the best users the best sommeliers
winemakers are using this app and I
think it's a big change in the wine more
collectible now it's gonna be is it cool
right now to take out your phone and
take a picture of a bottle I guess it is
going to be pretty cool pretty soon it's
cool to take out your phone and take a
picture of anything yeah I mean let's
call it and wine pictures everybody did
you see this by the way what does this
is gorgeous where'd you get this wrong I
mean these guys know I wish I did these
guys are cannibal I mean this is
incredible stuff I'm just just starved
so what we need a little something to
kind of like eat my word yeah you look
Perry White let me talk about that for a
second these are the perfect pairings
across the board on these four wines
we've got a Riesling which is number
three let's let why don't you try this
Mustang this is racist any winery this
is 10v but done hop one of the best
pieces in the world
we don't allow Cheers let's give it a
little world
what are you doing you need somebody
okay um I'm perfect I'm letting my
palate taste everything and notice
Rosanna not sweet
that is prejudiced you're a prejudiced
wine drinker my friend you thought a
Riesling was gonna be sweet but it's
both bone-dry don't make it sound like I
just committed a hate crime sweet wine
I mean look and the fact is 80% of
reasons are dry again tons of
misconceptions in the wine world we're
here to break into so on your app these
these wines that you brought us got good
ratings like this one got an eight point
two out of ten
yeah I mean look that one did the the
the fourth one might have not I mean to
me that's the part right I love the
becoming America's wine guy and people
followed me I'd much rather this be
democracy and people actually drink what
they like nobody asks what the rating of
ribs or a hamburger is you just know if
you like them and that's how wine should
be but we've been so scared by it it is
a little intimidating no Rosie can we
get back to the birthday yep is there a
favorite Rosie that you like this summer
because I feel like we have a short
window to drink when I say well first
you don't it's a summer thing because
it's fun to play but the truth is if you
like salads if you like shellfish
Rosie's great year-round that being said
that being said the Rosie's have changed
so much in the last five years because
everybody used to think of white
zinfandel and thought it was sweet these
dry roses are great go ahead my friend
no see you wonder why dry roses all of
your time five o'clock one more time I
want to see your book cover jib jib jab
right on out of here what is the right
hook part about selling I mean everybody
you know I mean everybody's on this
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram and
snapchat kick and the truth is that's
great but if you're unable to throw the
right hook look I just sat there before
I went on the air and I went to
cyberdust I went to Instagram I went to
Facebook I went to Twitter and I said
look I'm gonna be on that was able to
that was my right hook I wanted people
to stop doing what they were doing and
tune in and watch us and you and I are
wearing green
this you know mainly for the New York
Jets I'd like to everyone to understand
that the Jets have my thinking this
Thursday about that bye my son is my
it's fan might not we need to talk to
him okay
right hooks matter my friend if you
can't bring it into a conversion tune
into the show by the book you're
finished and seal the deal some melody
alright so I know you're involved with
the delectable yes what about resi
because I heard about this new app yeah
I think so resi resy I co-founded with
Ben Leventhal Mike Montero here in New
York it is an app to help people get
into restaurants that they could
normally not get into why can't they get
into Italy why not well because when you
go to open table it's available at 5:30
and 10:30 but if you want to get into
Gotham bar grill and miteta tavern or or
or you know rosemarys or charlie bird
and you want to get in within 10 or 15
minutes this app allows you to do that
so you have to pay to be a part of it
yes the app is free
yeah but if you want to get a table the
tables range between ten and twenty five
dollars a head so you're paying for the
access but the truth is everyone's
completely unaware of what's really
happening here in New York which is it's
all VIP you really can't get in and for
a couple of bucks you're getting the
best tables and the best time I like the
app if it fails though a twenty dollar
in your hand
hello Rosanna still that's that's and
you know what we want that to be part of
the game but let me tell you something
when you get out of a meeting and at
6:30 on a Thursday and you open the app
and you're able to get a seven thirty
table at the top ten restaurants in New
York that becomes interesting all right
if people are watching right now at home
and they have a startup business yeah
how best to use social media to your
advantage I mean you took your family's
videos they were doing well yep but now
they're doing extraordinarily well yep
what is the cake
the key is providing value jab jab jab
is give give give and then ask every
single person is just promoting on
Twitter
everything is watch my show look I said
watch the show but all weekend all last
week all for the last 30 days I'm
answering people's business questions
I'm giving them wine tips I'm taking
pictures and selfies for them I'm doing
whatever you have to give before we need
leverage
give then you're basically guilting
people into converting so every tweet
can't be you know two men this morning
we're on you
look you guys are icons in the city just
think oh well I don't know well new icon
in the side and so it just saying hello
to somebody saying they're watching
right now when this is over for you to
go searching your name and somebody said
great show today and you say thank you
that's the way to do it and nobody's
doing it guys nobody who's on television
who's a celebrity or a politician is
actually giving a call on a second you
got to read Rosanna's Twitter feed I
just got addicted to it I didn't respond
I didn't respond and I also because I
learned that I know you did I watched
you have amp your game and guess what
it's endless they really care they watch
him every morning you're a part of their
family and you jumping in saying sorry
or can I help you or thank you these are
real human emotions she has to say sorry
a lot that's Gary Vaynerchuk everybody
good stuff cheers pal thank you
graduations on everything